je me rends à son appartement quand
j'arrive il y a du champagne je suis
assez surprise mais bon je reste stoïque
et j'attends on échange on parle de
football féminin et lors de son
rendez-vous il me dit assez clairement
que si nous étions plus proche mes idées
se concrétiseraient en tout cas il
serait beaucoup plus motivé pour pour
m'aider dans ce sens et là en fait je me
prends une
claque énorme parce que excusez moi
d'être vulgaire mais mon président me
voit comme de ça et inclus en fait j'ai
été déçue par par mon Président pour moi
mon Président il doit être excusez-moi
mais
exemplaire on a l'impression vraiment
que c'est le roi et que la Fédération
Française de Football et son royaume
merci Michel Moulin ancien candidat à la
présidente de FFF Michel dans un instant
il y aura une petite bague pour toi pour
de Jean-Marie Bigard
de bienvenue Michel merci d'être là tu
as occupé des grandes fonctions au sein
du football tu t'es ensuite consacré à
la création du disport à codinaire
sportif à dominante foot et le 8 janvier
2021 t'annonce à conquis nature à la
présidence de la Fédération Française de
Football je sais
vous vous étiez je te tuto à Michel on
connaît bien tu t'étais présenté aussi
parce que tu voulais que ça change moi
bon
on était au courant que Monsieur le grec
aujourd'hui était à la fin de mandat
qu'il a des difficultés par sa maladie
par rapport à ça de temps en temps il
est tout le monde sait qu'il est de
temps un peu alcoolisé il faut pas se
cacher les choses et à partir de là il
dérape et
un moment aujourd'hui bon en dehors de
Zidane en plus je joue avec son frère en
ordin quand j'étais Aix-en-Provence et
que j'adore
ces gens-là je vous parle donc ça me
touche particulièrement mais je pense
que Monsieur le grec aujourd'hui c'est
pas que lui aujourd'hui tout le monde
lui tape dessus il a 8 ans
pour moi la dernière fois il a dérapé
parce que s'il était même pas audible
complètement donc il était certainement
entre les médicaments qui prend et
l'alcool qui boit peut-être dans un état
mais c'est tous les gens qui sont autour
de lui faut pas oublier que les gens ont
voté pour lui bien sûr le Comex et là
tout le monde parle du COMEX il se
battent pour avoir la place mais il faut
tous qu'ils soient virés il faut qu'il
quitte la Fédération tous tout ça que
Noëlle Noël doit démissionner parce que
là si démissionne pas on pourrait pas
comprendre mais c'est tous les autres
aujourd'hui il est couvert par tous les
autres vu le conseille aussi un peu ce
système et là aujourd'hui malgré alors
on va vous dire oui on peut pas parce
que il y a des lois il y a mais pour une
fois faut faire comme une entreprise
faut mettre des gens qui vont arriver
d'ailleurs qui vont pendant un certain
temps reprendre cette fédération pour
mettre les choses bien on parle de
Michel Platini c'est sur la meilleure
personne pour être président et on peut
rigoler plus loin on peut dire DTN par
exemple
Zinédine Zidane Yazid pour être
directeur technique il faut mettre les
meilleurs frais inédits comment il le
ferait ça je sais pas
toujours comme des entreprises les
meilleurs retours de soi bien sûr et
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça moi j'ai
toujours tenues j'ai tenu vous savez
ParuVendu j'avais 3000 emplois j'étais
loin d'être le meilleur j'ai été entouré
des meilleurs marketing de meilleure
informaticien et qui m'aider à être bon
le problème il est là et aujourd'hui il
faut faire un management de transition
pour faire des élections dans un an ou
deux ans organisé parce que si au fond
des élections là on va retomber sur des
gens qui étaient avec Monsieur le grec
et c'est bon les blancs
la plupart des gens Cyril ne connaissent
pas le football ils sont là par
opportuniste nous on est des passionnés
moi je connais très bien le foot amateur
on est on est des vrais passionnés il
parlait de statut de bénévoles il y a
bientôt plus de bénévoles ils ont pas
fait de statut l'arbitrage il s'en
occupe pas la sécurité alors on en parle
pas moi tout le monde m'a dit j'avais
mis monsieur square signé avec moi c'est
un scandale mais Real de Madrid
Liverpool il aurait plus de problème
c'est ce soir cini donc ces gens ils
doivent quitter la Fédération et malgré
que les statues nous disent oui il faut
pas il faut faire le management de
transition tant qu'on ne peut pas
utiliser faire une des vraies élections
avec des gens normaux et des gens qui
sont qui connaissent le football et le
management chill ça bouge un petit peu
aujourd'hui quand même parce que donc le
comité d'éthique mais il y a aussi
demain un comité exécutif extraordinaire
qui se réunit et ça vient au lendemain
de l'audition de Monsieur le greffe pour
ce fameux audit dont on attend les
résultats donc c'est fidèle se
réunissent le matin le comité exécutif
après peut-être que certains de ces
fidèles comme le disait Michel Moulin
voilà ils vont commencer à se dire là on
va tous couler avec toi peut-être que il
faut que tu tires les conclusions je
pense que mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait moi
je pense qu'il partira pas non plus
si c'est si son carré fidèle lui dit là
on va tous mourir avec toi tu vas tuer
la fédé 20 ans peut-être que ça peut
partir ou jamais moi si j'étais lui j'ai
81 ans bien sûr j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de
partir il lui reste combien de reste un
an c'est ça
que que vous dites Gilles mais ils sont
là il y a que deux l'élection il y a pas
de vingt ans qu'elle a eu lieu et demi
bien sûr donc ils sont de connivence
avec lui oui mais tout le monde va
essayer de sauver ses fesses aussi
peut-être tout le monde va essayer de se
baisser facilement
c'est pas la le eux qu'il faut sauver
c'est l'entité le football
ces gens n'ont rien à faire dans le
football avec vous mais vous pensez pas
qu'il va être quand même poussé par la
sortie par ces gens-là qui l'ont d'abord
soutenu oui
deux jours après la police
Sonia sweat puis tout ce qui sort plus
le dit plus plein de choses plus moi
plus jeunes filles je les fais démarrer
alors vous pouvez l'appeler au départ je
l'ai aidé pour être agent de joueurs
cette jeune fille alors monsieur je
défends pas du tout Noël je connais pas
ce que tu veux et tu fais ce que tu veux
tout ils font pas du tout et je mets pas
du tout en cause en doute les les
accusations de Sonia swed mais elle est
pas la seule il y en a plein d'autres
bien sûr mais à chaque fois on reproduit
le même principe c'est une chasse à
courre un homme est blessé et tout le
monde se jette sur lui c'est le faire là
de sortir je crois qu'il me l'a dit ça
date depuis 10 ans 2013 à 2007 ça fait
10 ans et voilà tout à coup boom l'homme
est blessé et tous les chiens se jettent
sur lui il va d'autres affaires qui vont
sortir quand même un peu un peu énervant
la longue quoi là-dessus
tu es d'accord avec Jean-Michel là je
suis d'accord aussi et surtout ce qui va
alors attention je veux pas déraper moi
aussi j'adore Zidane mais ce qui est
drôle c'est que tous les dérapages
d'avant donc il y a eu les affaires
sexuels il y a eu le fait qu'il a dit
qu'effectivement il y a eu 6000 morts au
Qatar tout le monde s'en fout que
l'homophobie tout le monde s'en fout le
racisme tout le monde s'en fout et
personne n'a réagi sur rien mais on
dirait un mot sur Zidane scandale
j'adore Zidane mais tout ce qu'on a dit
avant c'est-à-dire le racisme le phobie
les morts tout ça tout le monde s'en
fout parce que parce que ils sont tous à
sabotent donc tout le monde ferme sa
gueule et bien un jour il s'attaque un
plus gros que lui et là que d'un coup
tout le monde se demande voilà c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça qu'ils vont
peut-être commencer à ouvrir leurs
gueules de ma paix
à partir du moment pardonnez-moi ou bapé
qui est notre star absolu notre nouvelle
légende sans mail je pense que le grec
du coup a du souci à se faire parce
qu'il ne pourra pas rester parce que ma
pilule a un moyen de pression il pourra
dire mais moi je ne joue plus dans cette
sélection si le grec reste à la tête
comme ça il a ce pouvoir là parce qu'il
est il est hors norme et donc je pense
que moi Noël le gratte c'est fini donc
quelque temps mais c'est fini très vite
moi je pense qu'il partira pas moi aussi
j'étais lui je partirai pas
partira pas il va pas partir il va
partir il va pas partir
sur plusieurs personnes et de ça quand
vous êtes un peu âgées et malade la
seule chose qui vous tient parfois envie
c'est le boulot et le moment où vous
lâchez de l'eau pas lâcher moi je veux
dire ça va se tasser les affaires et il
va rester et puis dans 2 ans il partira
Michel oui oui mais c'est pas bien pour
le football surtout le football amateur
parce que là on parle que là on parle
que de la vitrine de l'équipe de France
il faut voir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans les clubs amateurs là aujourd'hui
dans la dans la Méditerranée le district
du Vaucluse a démissionné il y a un très
gros problème dans le disque de Provence
personne ne dirait ça pète de partout et
il y a des petits là faut savoir de les
il y a l'éducation de nos enfants il y a
beaucoup de choses derrière il faut pas
oublier tout ça merci en tout cas Michel
Moulin nous avait éclairé
là-dessus on va voir ce qui va se passer
dans le prochain jour moi je pense qu'il
ne partira pas